she fought to flip her house seat red
and tomorrow new york
congresswoman-elect nicole malliotakis
will officially be sworn into congress
where she will cast her first vote for
house speaker but with a slim path to
victory can nancy pelosi hold on to her
gavel that's the big question well let's
ask the congresswoman elect herself
nicole meliotakas nicole welcome to the
show and congratulations to you
obviously this is a big day
for you tomorrow getting sworn in we
want to get your thoughts on that and we
also want to get your thoughts on this
new found well i don't know how much how
newfound it is actually pushback against
nancy pelosi and whether you think that
will go anywhere
well happy new year and thank you for
having me uh what i can tell you is that
last time she was elected speaker there
were 15 democrats who did not
vote for her 10 of those are returning
and the majority is less than that
and so we have an opportunity to see a
new speaker
we even have an opportunity for kevin
mccarthy to become speaker depending how
things play out who shows up
to actually do their job but what i can
tell you
is that regardless of who is speaker
there's an opportunity
for the democrats and republicans to
work together
to shut out the socialist squad that's
what the democrats should be aiming to
do quite frankly because they had so
many losses this year
and this is their opportunity to work
with us to get things done in a
bipartisan manner
you know nicole one of the things that
you've been really passionate about is
defending law enforcement and i you know
police in particular
firefighters i think that was one of the
chief reasons that you actually won
knowing how staten island voters felt
about those issues but you recently
called on governor cuomo and mayor de
blasio in the form of a letter actually
to prioritize the nypd when it comes to
getting the covid 19 vaccine here's a
segment of that letter we have here
it is unconscionable to think our law
enforcement officers are not considered
at risk enough to get the vaccine
immediately
the members of the nypd are first
responders they have thousands of close
contact interactions every day
law enforcement is our front line and we
have a responsibility
to protect them your thoughts
our local government unfortunately has
turned their back on our law enforcement
whether it be to defund the police
movement whether it be the bail reform
whether it be cuomo's
parole board releasing 16 cop killers
over the last three years we are
constantly seeing them being
disrespected by our local leaders
i continue to stand without nypd and i
know because they're the front line they
cannot
work from home they're dealing with
people on a regular basis they need to
be high up on this priority list
in fact governor cuomo bumped them down
to give the vaccination instead to
individuals who are in rehab
and so i think that they're number one
it's an issue of getting this
vaccination out as you read
the other day the new york post they
have the vaccinations they're just not
administering them quickly enough and
i'm demanding answers from our mayor and
governor as to why
yeah an important point there also
important to note we reached out to the
offices of governor andrew cuomo and
mayor bill de blasio we have not
heard back as of yet we'll keep you
informed nicole thanks for being here
and congratulations to you once again
thank you